secret societies electrified gender
roles and a post-apocalyptic Adventure
backed by some of the biggest names in
fantasy these mystical book to TV
adaptations are slated for the small
screen
Sarah J Maas is one of the most popular
fantasy romance authors working today
and her a court of thorns and Roses
Series has helped introduce a number of
new readers to the genre the first book
in the series centered on a human
Huntress who is taken to the neighboring
fairy realm has sold millions of copies
worldwide so there is Adventure and lots
and lots of romance and another complex
interesting heroine Outlander fans
should be particularly excited for this
adaptation a series Creator Ronald D
Moore is heading the project while there
probably won't be any time travel Accord
to thorns and Roses is just as steamy
and even more magical than the
long-running Showtime series based on
the novels of Diana Gabaldon we don't
know much more about the TV adaptation
which may be due to the fact that the
series order leaked long before it was
supposed to be announced in fact Mass's
husband may have been the first to LEAP
the news in an Instagram post about a
sandwich which then led to the author
herself making a more complete
announcement on her own Instagram page
though it seems the series is still a
ways off fans can expect it to stream on
Hulu once it does drop
Red Queen gives readers an interesting
Twist on classism with the premise that
a person's blood color determines where
they stand in the social structure of
Victoria aveyard's fantasy world and red
queen those with red blood are typical
commoners while those born with silver
blood in their veins have god-like
powers and are seen as royalty bands of
Game of Thrones will be familiar with
the power struggle in this novel and the
Planned TV adaptation should bring in
viewers of similar taste according to
variety Red Queen has a series order at
peacock and is being spearheaded by
Hunger Games actress Elizabeth Banks the
star is set to direct produce and play a
supporting role in the series Banks
originally wanted to adapt Red Queen to
film back in 2015. however since there
are now a number of sequels the series
may be a better fit for the project
Lee bardugo has already seen massive
success with her books as part of her
grishaverse novels have already been
turned into a Netflix series however
ninth house is completely separate from
bardugo's Shadow and Bone universe and
even falls under a different fantasy
novel subgenre bardugo's 2019 novel is a
paranormal fantasy crossed with a murder
mystery ninth house takes place at Yale
where there are nine secret societies
within the university the book explores
the magic behind each the first novel in
the series centers around Galaxy Alex
Stern who's investigating a campus
murder according to deadline bardugo is
acting as executive producer for the
series which was purchased by Amazon
studios in a lively bidding war puya
sarbazian who adapted the Divergent
series and bardugo's own shadow and Bone
books is also a producer on the project
the TV adaptation of Naomi Alderman's
feminist sci-fi fantasy novel to power
began casting in 2019 and started
production a year later unfortunately
production was halted shortly thereafter
due to the pandemic the series is back
in development but reshoots will need to
happen as cast members Leslie Mann and
Tim Robbins dropped from the Caster in
the long Hiatus the series takes place
in an alternate universe where women
developed the ability to send an
electrical current through their fingers
which affords them positions of power
over their male counterparts what
women and not men were the sex who could
do more physical harm who could cause
more pain it has been compared to
Margaret Atwood's The handmaid's Tale
and in fact Atwood was a mentor to
aldermen fans are patiently waiting for
the series which will premiere on Amazon
Prime in 2023
Westworld star Tessa Thompson is moving
into the production game she opened her
own development company and already has
several book to TV adaptations in the
works according to deadline Thompson and
Game of Thrones author George R.R Martin
are developing an HBO series based on
nediocorofor's hoopier's death akoraphor
will also act as co-executive producer
on the series who fears death is a
coming-of-age story about a girl born
into a violent post-apocalyptic North
Africa where their entire culture facing
Mass genocide protagonistonia sowu whose
name literally translates to who fears
death is destined to save her people I
didn't hold back anything when I wrote
that the book is a heavy read and the
series is likely to be just as
hard-hitting and moving especially
considering the massive Talent it has
behind it
Rick Riordan has found great success in
the young adult fantasy genre and his
Greek mythology-based Percy Jackson in
the Olympian series was already turned
into a two film series with 2010's Percy
Jackson and the Olympians the Lightning
Thief the original book series is
comprised of Five Books the Riordan has
released a number of other series and
companion pieces set in the same
universe with such an expansive
collection of works it makes sense that
a TV series would be the way to tell the
entire story Riordan laid out with his
intense World building mythology and
complex characters the upcoming
reimagining of Percy Jackson and the
Olympians will land on Disney plus and
although Rick Riordan seems more on
board with the series than he was with
the previous films Percy Jackson and the
Olympians is really
truly and for sure coming to your
screens deadline notes of both Riordan
and his wife are acting as executive
producers on the series and in an
interview with the guardian the author
said he felt he owed it to his fans to
give them a new on-screen version of The
Beloved series Riordan told the guardian
that he feels optimistic that Disney can
do a much better job than the films did
in bringing his work to life something
fans should be excited to hear the
famously honest author Express
the Percy Jackson series isn't the only
fantasy based on Greek mythology to
achieve recent popularity Madeleine
Miller Cersei has also been met with
high enough Acclaim to Merit an
adaptation the book is a retelling of
various Greek myths that contain
elements of the classic tale The Odyssey
it reads like a legendary epic centered
on a female protagonist the novel
centers on the minor Greek goddess and
enchantress Cersei as she deals with the
moral ramifications of creating a
monster responsible for many deaths
she's also the first witch in Western
literature which is itself a very
interesting thing the Standalone novel
topped the New York Times bestseller
list won the 2019 Indie Choice audiobook
of the Year award and has appeared on
many best of lists according to a 2020
announcement from deadline Cersei is
getting the TV series treatment with an
8 episode series order from HBO Max
writers Rick Jaffa and Amanda silver who
have previously collaborated on high
profile projects such as Jurassic world
and Rise of the Planet of the Apes or
again teaming up to write produce the
scripts for the adaptation originally
announced back in 2019 there is no set
release date yet for social but we could
potentially see the series hit HBO in
another fantasy novel that saw a
competitive bidding war for the
on-screen adaptation rights as Rebecca
Rowan horse's black son which is set to
premiere on AMC in the near future The
Hollywood Reporter announced that Angela
Kang will head up the project as
executive producer Kang worked on the
iconic AMC series The Walking Dead for
over a decade and was promoted to
showrunner during season nine Rowan
horse will also have a heavy hand in the
TV adaptation as she has also been named
as an executive producer the American
writer has authored multiple sci-fi and
fantasy novels and she has also
contributed writing to Marvel's Phoenix
song Echo Comics Laxon is the first
novel in the between Earth and Sky
series it takes place in a world where
celestial events are a source of magic
and power the story centers on four main
characters whose pass and missions
converge to dramatic and sometimes
violent effects with roots in both
history and politics black son manages
to be a fun read with an impactful
message this alone makes Angela Kang a
great choice to head the project and she
has successfully helped create this sort
of atmosphere in The Walking Dead across
multiple seasons
Neil Gaiman is one of the top names in
the fantasy genre and a number of his
novels have already been turned into
either films or TV series Lucifer is a
popular Netflix series with a lead
character based on one of gaiman's
characters from The Sandman Comics
Sandman recently received its own
adaptation on the same streaming
platform Coraline good Omens and
American Gods are all popular
adaptations of gay men's novels as well
I believe what do you believe shadow
[Music]
everything in 2021 variety announced the
limited series order of six episodes for
gaimans and antsy boys to be produced by
Amazon Studios sets in the same universe
as American Gods Neil gaiman's and ANSI
boys centers around the twin sons of Mr
Nancy however Mr Nancy turns out to be a
Nancy a deity first introduced in
American Gods when Mr Nancy dies his son
Charlie discovers his father's true
identity as a trickster God and that he
has a twin brother with whom he soon
reunites unlike a lot of the platform's
other ongoing fantasy adaptations Amazon
is moving quickly on a Nancy boys
variety's announcement noted that the
series is already fully cast with
Malachi Kirby playing the Dual role of
Mr Nancy's twin Sons the series seems to
have already finished filming and is in
post-production although there is
currently no set date for when it will
drop to Amazon Prime
RF quangs the poppy war is the first
book in a Trilogy that combines the
Legends and myths of ancient China with
a fantasy world full of shamanism and
Monsters the novel centers around Rin an
orphaned girl who Against All Odds
passes the test for acceptance into an
elite Military Academy and is mentored
by a mysterious master who unlocks her
hidden magical abilities a story that
follows is one of honors civic
responsibility and sacrifice according
to deadline Peter luo's Starlight media
has optioned the rights to the poppy war
in addition Starlight media has acquired
the rights to both the second and third
book in the trilogy setting in motion
plans to develop the award-winning
novels into an expansive TV series the
company has previously backed projects
like the critically acclaimed film crazy
Rich Asians it's unclear where or when
the series will be available and if it
is already in development as further
details remain Under Wraps
book talk a section of the social media
platform Tick Tock that indulges in all
things literature and has helped sell
and spread the word about a number of
self-published books that may have never
taken off without it I'll be Blake's the
atlas 6 is one such book after going
viral on the video sharing platform
deadline reports that the book became
the subject of an intense bidding battle
between networks looking to buy the
rights Amazon emerged as the Victor and
fans of the atlas 6 can look forward to
a streamable series in the future
Partners Tanya sagachian and John
Woodward will be acting as executive
producers through their company bright
star the pair also worked together on
the Oscar winning film The Power of the
dog sagachian also gained repute working
on the first four Harry Potter films and
the Netflix series The Crown the atlas 6
centers around six chosen magicians
whose power is immense even in a world
full of magic and Sorcerers they are
competing against each other for a place
among the most powerful secret society
in the world for magic wheelers in the
Cutthroat competition the sixth balance
growing closer to each other against the
inevitable betrayal the competition will
bring with several other books published
including a sequel to The Atlas 6 and
safe to assume this TV series won't be
the last time Blake's name makes
headlines
[Music]